joining me is human sunshine ross
matthew
hi hi hi and our guest today which i am
so
excited about is um as a giant of the
nfl
at today's show correspondent really so
many correspondents
actually was like marveling at his
resume because we're syndicated show and
it's so nice to just
work across the isles and he's now the
host of cbs sports radio as well
where we heard he has seen the show and
we are such fans of his we reached right
out and here he is tiki barber hi
hi how you guys doing good to see you
guys oh my gosh i can't believe this
this is so full circle chris batary
thank you literally my friend chris was
like tiki barbara's talking about your
show right now
on the radio and so we asked to see if
you come on we're such
huge fans of yours thank you so much for
coming
it is my pleasure i'm a huge fan of
yours and you know what it was election
day and everyone's stressing about the
election and i see you
on your new show which i didn't know
about until i saw it playing with
puppies i was like this makes me feel so
good drewberry boy
with puppies i'm i'm hooked i'm dead
sullivan from the news had the idea to
bring them on
and it was true and two of them got
adopted here so
but let's talk about bats balls and
bubbles because it's
time for sports sports
okay everybody knows that thanksgiving
means football but this time it also
meant making history because on saturday
saturday vanderbilt university senior
sarah fuller became the first woman
ever to play in a power five college
football game
i mean this girl is
so cool so rad
i can't even handle it tiki what is the
significance of this
yeah this was an amazing story and i
fell in love with it as soon as i saw it
and it was because of necessity
vanderbilt had already broken for
thanksgiving holiday so there were no
kids on campus
there was no like maybe played in high
school kicker that could have tried out
for the team
and sarah was still there because
vanderbilt soccer
had just played in the sec championship
and they obviously won the championship
so she was there
the head coach said hey can you come
kick for us she said absolutely
unfortunately vanderbilt was not very
good so they didn't get close to scoring
so she didn't get the score but she did
kick
off which made her the first woman in
power five history those are the big
schools
in college football
okay our next story after the success of
the nba and wnba bubbles the washington
post reports that nfl
is now considering whether to create one
for the post season
and they've made no announcements no
decisions have been made but tiki
what do you think about the idea of
local bubbles for teams so we can keep
carrying on
i think it might be necessary i don't
know how far how much you follow the nfl
drew
so well you saw the denver bronco
tiki you wouldn't think that looking at
me but i'm a huge football fan
i'm a big fan of the seahawks i'm
watching monday night football tonight
out of
outdoors there you know what i'm rooting
for you because you need to beat the
eagles who are the
the enemy of my giants so yeah yeah yeah
good good i hear that but the denver
broncos this past weekend
had four players and they happened to be
quarterbacks
who either had the corona virus or were
contact trained they couldn't start a
quarterback
yeah they started a wide receiver a
walk-on wide receiver at quarterback who
never practiced
so yes i think they actually are going
to need a bubble to get through the
postseason otherwise
these things could get canceled and we
don't want to see that happen agreed and
i think it's just
2020 hoosier pod yeah exactly
and like what does being in a bubble
mean it means sort of staying in a hotel
room between games right ordering room
service
can i be a player sign me up yeah yeah
exactly except for when you're there
except when you're there for three
months like the nba was and
you're kind of well that means i finally
get through the crown and
i made every show possible during
thanksgiving
but tiki i just can't thank you enough
for stopping by
and you know you're such an important
figure
and i love your whole career and
the fact that you know now we're sort of
trying to do what you do
we could never have played football so
we have to copy this side of your life
you guys are fantastic you never know
my mom played football my mom played she
put on the pads
played football when i was a kid sarah
fuller who are you gonna be a
football player yeah um i'm gonna get
old school steve largent number eighty
seahawks
hey back in the day the 80s go along
steve would you please come back and do
more sports with us
i would love to
[Music]